hi I'm rashida Jones and I'm at Wired
where it's all work and all play I am
co-writing toy story for my writing
partner will McCormick I just wrapped on
a new TV show called Angie Tribeca for
TBS which comes out on the fall will and
I have a TV production company which
just finished a pilot for ABC Family
drama called Nicks my dad gives really
good advice but he told me to pick two
things to pursue just get really good at
those things and know everything you can
about those two things feel lucky that
you can that you're able to do something
that you love because that's that is a
huge gift I kind of live and work for
those moments when you have an idea that
doesn't feel like it's yours or belongs
to you like you're just you just happen
to be there and it came to you and you
happen to be available to that idea and
then everybody else thinks that you're
talented or grave because that idea came
to you and not them but it doesn't ever
really feel like mine it's just nice to
know of it
I'm awake to get that idea so those
those are the moments
if I if I weren't doing the jobs that
I'm doing now I don't know there's a lot
of things I'd like to do I would like to
be a novelist I'd like to work for NGOs
I would like to do something in nature I
don't know I kind of have like a strange
fantasy about about being like a park
ranger just being looks animals
wire take one